we told you yesterday about a courageous
act of defiance by a russian journalist
she interrupted a broadcast on state
television with a message opposing the
war in ukraine today we're learning more
about her fate and deborah patta has
that story for us
marina of sanakova on the steps outside
the russian court that found her guilty
of an illegal protest where she remained
defiant it was my own anti-war decision
i
don't like
russia starts this
invasion
stopped the war she burst onto the
evening news with a sign saying don't
believe propaganda they are lying to you
here afsanakova was promptly arrested
and interrogated without her lawyer or
being allowed to make phone calls for
over 14 hours she's been fined 280
dollars but could still face more
serious charges
after all protesting the war in vladimir
putin's russia is dangerous business and
this was high profile the news broadcast
is the flagship state tv show with
millions of viewers every day but her
lawyer anton gashinski told us of
sanikova is committed to speaking out
we've seen what happens to dissenters in
russia in the past is she worried about
her safety
of course she is worried she has said
that during the court hearing but she
also said there was no option for her
but to do this
earlier this month the russian
government criminalized any comments
about the military it deems false but
this brave mother of two says citizens
cannot remain silent for cbs mornings
deborah patter london